[Music]
so today we're going to go over the
viewers choice and you're sent a handful
of game but there could be more and if
you do want to send in your games feel
free to send it to this link right here
or this link one of the links not
balanced okay send it to this one and if
you email it to us we'll be really
excited and then we might go over it
very much sure if it's a decent math
game so today we're going to start with
okay some some games sent in from toxic
toxic hunter and I believe these were
all chefs comm games and I actually have
seven games in the database all of which
flight one so I don't know what it is
with sending in games at light one but
hopefully they'll be entertaining okay
and the thing about toxic hunter is he
plays b3 on move one in all of these
games and he wins without too much
effort so out of the people here who
play chess have you guys seen this move
b3 on move one sometimes what about you
son Simon it's kind of a more modern
move this is called the Larson opening
where white is trying to play Bishop e2
and then attack the center basically
just with the bishop with the Fein keto
now it's known to be a little bit
passive and I'm not entirely impressed
with what that Lisa opening in most of
these games but we'll we'll take a look
this game knight c6 it should be 2 e 5 e
3 9 of 6 and Bishop to b5 and this is
actually a very common position for the
Larson opening and White's main idea is
to essentially pressure the e5 pawn
where right now like trying to take on
c6 and then just take on e5 and the
question is what to do for black
how does lack the semi five pond and
it's actually a little bit awkward for
back and here are black way to move
which is reasonable v6 but it's not the
best move so I'll leave it up to you
guys can you find a different move for
black which defends the e5 pawn I think
you mean Bishop d6 yeah and Bishop d6 is
actually a better move even though it
looks awkward because you're blocking
your your D pawn which in turn blocks
the bishop a lot of times what happens
is later on if this should take Knights
pawn technics and then this Bishop is
actually really well placed 96 now one
of the main lines here is that if whites
just kind of continues normal
development let's say Knights e to then
black can provoke the bishop to take the
knife and in this case white will
usually take plastics back and blacks
should be relatively happy here another
move that I like to play and actually
went over this in a previous YouTube
video maybe Ben diamond can do some
research and like link it somewhere but
the move I like here for Black is efore
because what this does is it removes the
target on e5 completely and now this
Bishop is just kind of staring at the
knight which is well defended and I've
actually had a few games with E for I
might as well just show it again in case
people haven't seen the previous video
where black gets a very early initiative
and just a reminder for everyone make
sure your phones are on silent okay so
after E for light will normally play and
move like 92 /jj six the bishop in this
case has to take the knife if the bishop
doesn't take the Knights say Bishop c4
then black can play d5 and tactics are
very important here because the bishop
is not fast and Bishop is a lost black
will be open so after Bishop takes c6
yep yeah disobey for that's a good point
normally this is the type of move you
want to play but not with your phone on
B 3 and B 5 will happen your Bishop gets
tracked so it's really important to kind
of be aware of the tactics in the
opening soak Bishop takes you six pawn
take and now the games I've had in this
position and gone where my opponent
castles I played this would be six they
play d3 and now from here black is
winning with the next move and now the
next move isn't obvious to a lot of
players so I think I'll just walk
through it it's kind of a classic what's
called the Greek gift sacrifice where
black can take on h2
an idea is black is giving up a bishop
but then getting a checkmating attack
with the knight and queen so after king
tic 94 King goes back point h4 whites in
really big trouble
and there's actually I don't think any
way for white to survive here if I'm not
mistaken if rook e1 then I mean White's
whole queen like cold King side falls
apart
Queen take F to King h1 and then
probably a nice Wilfork like 93 with
idea we're threatening the Queen and
threatening made anyone and if you're
ever going to fork something it's
usually best to force the Queen and
checkmate
those are that like the two best things
so if we move back why had to be very
careful and the mistake for whites was
probably castling too early but actually
the decisive mistake is d3 here what
like should do is kind of be aware that
this should take you choose a threat and
then play something like h3 or Knight g3
but then black still has fun for example
93 perhaps a move maybe h5 actually
don't know if this works tactically but
probably h5 because if this should take
f6
take white would like to take the e4
pawn but they wrote cos hanging and this
is one of the issues for white in this
opening is when white plays kind of
passively and restricted and if last
dates actively and precisely then it's
usually white he's under fire first so
let's go back to what happened the game
but let's look at this move d6 because
from this game like got like a really
nice position and that eventually won
now I do have one story behind d6 when I
was a much lesser experienced player I
was still decent I had no idea what to
play against this opening as black and I
used to play this move d6 and there was
a game I played online I think it was
like back in high school so like five
six years ago and I play Leonce Nakamura
and now I've played Nakamura like maybe
fifty to a hundred times over the course
of my life and the only game I ever beat
him was with black in this opening after
d6 and if we know Nakamura he's like top
wits player in the world I managed to
beat him because he like over pushed and
then I got lucky
so okay let's look at this game d4
yeah and white white has a nice position
because this bishop has a nice kind of
long opening open diagonal and this is
kind of a dream of the the fiend kettle
ditches
so take tick - 3 the 793 so both sides
doing climate development and then what
eventually happened it became a pretty
chart because black wants to attack on
the Queen side white wants to attack on
the King side and this is very common
especially for these off the pie casting
positions you want to go for a quicker
attack than your opponent now here white
played a pretty good move by played a 4
which essentially slows down blacks
attack the black would like to play a
for himself and then open up the file
but when white plays a four kind of the
black pawns form is slow down so luckily
Queen g7 perhaps threatening b5 this
would be 5 never happened
Queen d3 h6
and now the next several moves I really
like from lights because white
understood that material wasn't so
important and that initiative and attack
was a lot more important
so what white did was just kind of
sacrifice and black took everything that
was free and then got made it so the
first sacrifice we see is Nike for now
can anyone spot what the free pawn is
that black can capture a4 is upon that
black can capture but it's not free or
because it's defended twice right well
there's there's another pawn that can be
captured by the bishop
yeah g2 and it looks completely free
like not defended might as well take it
you attack the rook and that's what
black did but this was a huge mistake
because it opens up the G file and in
this position for whites the G file is
more important than just upon the G file
will lead to a very strong attack and
that's very common especially when
you're attacking user your main goal is
to open up your files or the files on
the air of the board where your rooks
can come into play so here white takes
advantage of that very quickly from hg 1
bishop h3 and now a very nice sacrifice
Knight to d5 and this move looks strange
at first because the Knights not
defended and then I can just take and of
course that's what black did I take t5
and now a pretty incredible sequence of
moves from light and this was um I was
actually pretty impressive because I
don't know if I would have found like
this whole sequence myself
so any ideas here what to do for whites
maybe I should put in on training mode
so you guys can't cheat no that's five
yeah so the main point here is you you
want to target g7 because here a rook
and your Bishop are already kind of
aimed at g7 and 9s five does put another
attacker and then there were there would
be three attackers
and I think 905 is is a really good move
but white probably just played a
stronger move and use a similar idea but
a bit more forcing so instead of playing
Knight f5 first
white takes on g7 first and this is more
forcing because the king has to take and
then you play nine f5 or maybe something
else and the king will be a lot more
exposed and black really has no choice
had to take so if we see so far wide
sacrifice upon the Knights and the rook
but now it's going to be completely
winning for wiped his attack is too
strong and yeah not Knight a5 at 96 very
strong double check
Knight and Bishop attacking King
whenever it's double check the King has
to move you can never like deal with the
two pieces checking the King on the
other way
King g8 and now we see the open G files
very nice for for white and yeah it's
rook to you one check black is running
out options black plays Bishop to g5 and
that was simply Knight to g5 and even
though this move maybe isn't a check
doesn't seem entirely forcing it's still
really putting the pressure on black
because any Knight move will be a check
likewise threatening a bunch of
discovery checks and basically every
single white teeth but still on the
board is directed at the black King and
this is really important when you're
attacking that you use like all the
pieces you can so here what was really
resourceful with every single piece
knife six was played and now Knight h7
check a nice sneaky move the knight
can't be taken the rook deliver to check
Queen g4 was played which is a pretty
sad move like what else to do if if this
move Bishop to g4 then they take a six
check and it's a triple fork we don't
really care about the bishop but we're
we're winning the Queen at least when
we're probably meeting very soon
actually we are mating very soon because
if the King moves here to g7 or h8 there
is Queen age 17 and something similar
happened in the game after 97 clean g4
white didn't take the Queen white just
takes the knight first
King g7 still doesn't take the Queen
when you're 17 so this was a really nice
kind of example of attacking play and
kind of using all your pieces to their
maximum potential the mistake of a lot
of chess players is they'll try and
attack with one piece and usually those
attacks are not as effective um maybe we
can take a look at one more toxic Hunter
game because he played another nice game
with with b3 and all his games it looks
like he played three games with b3 as
whites and won all of them in under 30
moves so let's look at this one here is
opponent played slightly differently and
actually uh several like kind of early
mistakes were made in the opening and I
do want to make a point here that when
you're playing in the opening you kind
of want to look for the best for your
pieces in relation to your opponent's
setup and what I mean by that is you
don't want to put your square or your
pieces on players which could be taken
advantage of and black did something
kind of went against that rule in this
position by playing Bishop to c5 and
normally this is like a decent
developing move just put your bishop in
the center but in this position the
bishop doesn't stand well on c5 because
it's just staring at this pawn chain and
one of the whites main plans is to play
d4 and later on okay if I played
correctly and like gets in d4 then the
bishop will likely have to move again
and you never want to be like moving the
same piece twice too early on
now I didn't play entirely correctly
here what white should have done was
play nice TAC three just developing the
knight attacking the pawn and then
preparing d4 and this would have given
white some some nice early initiative
instead what white did was very strange
and white played kind of a fancy move it
looks like kind of a cool tactic but it
turns out to just be positioning that
play Bishop take me five at first this
looks like a blunder because my taking
five whites just lost a bishop for upon
White's point was he now plays d4 and
he's winning back either the bishop for
the night the problem with this kind of
sequence of moves for whites is he's
giving away or he just gave away his
best piece the bishop was only developed
piece
his pawn structure is kind of set up so
the bishop is a good Bishop and Bishop
taking five essentially trade Bacchus is
good vision
so after take and d4 now it's black to
move and I actually want a at least the
chess players here to think and decide
whether you would rather keep the
Knights or keep the bishop you can only
keep one piece so which piece would you
rather save for the rest of the game
okay so both of you would rather keep
the knife from fortunate the wrong
answer much rather keep your bishop and
the reason why is because white already
gave away his dark for Bishop which
means that white will be less able to
kind of control the dark squares on the
board so it's very important if your
opponent ever gives away a bishop of a
certain color you want to keep that same
bishop of the same color and in this
case you would much rather keep the
bishop for black so the best move here
is actually just move the bishop back it
supports the night and after white takes
takes then this Bishop is incredibly
incredibly powerful actually targeting
some some weak points in White's
position it's interesting here white
only has one move one good move to save
the rook c3 nekkid and
nice defense III but if we know this
white pieces art is completely
undeveloped and black can further
development maybe minus six
d5 and black already has a really
comfortable provision but I see this
mistake so often and this is one of the
I guess separating factors between kind
of beginner level players and more
advanced players is they pay very close
attention to which pieces are keeping on
the board in which pieces
trading off and we're actually going to
see yeah we see black check the the King
plays c3 and now black is in a situation
to still preserve the bishop black can
still play Bishop d6 but of course black
gave away the bishop which is not the
right thing to do like took back and now
White's doing really well because white
has the two central pawns has initiative
because this might have so attacked and
it's funny because both sides kind of
made the same mistake very early on both
sides gave away their dark for Bishop
when it was completely not necessary so
this was more of a traditional mistake
rather than task mistake but okay later
on the game will definitely see some
tactics so 96 let's continue next three
b6 and yeah I really liked White's
position Bishop d3 was played I think
this should be 5 is just a bit more
aggressive like this is a move you kind
of dream of pinning the night lights not
defended you're threatening to take the
knight and fork the king and rook so
blacks a little bit if you hear black
would have to play Bishop to d7 and then
we could continue adding pressure with a
move like 95 probably a better option
for whites but if we go back Bishop d3
was played let's go forward a bit
quicker a 6 was kind of weird rook c1
like before the right move would be to
preserve this Bishop right now it's
attacked by the knife and again you
don't want to trade off like the good
bishop for an opponent's night so where
can the bishop go in this position where
it can't be taken and there should be
one I know it looks like weird to be
moving all the way backwards so the
bishop maintains its life long diagonal
and it's like ever castles King side
then the bishop is already placed pretty
well to attack and maybe white could
organize some up some more attack maybe
with a3 eventually Queen b3 create some
mating ideas on h7 this was pretty
common where you you want to preserve
your bishop especially if it's on the
diagonal
okay let's go forward rookie one was
played like gave away the bishop
eventually black took and we're going to
zoom forward because things got traded
off the position transformed a little
bit now it's kind of a classic night
versus Bishop scenario and more of the
time when especially when it's an open
position the bishop is normally slightly
better than the Knights but in this
position I would probably prefer the
knight a bit more just because it's so
nicely centralized and blacks pieces
aren't really working together in any
way like the Queen and the two rooks are
still like completely undeveloped and
whites Queen and rooks are on nicely
placed on open e-file and a half open
sea files so Bishop d5 was played Queen
c2 attacking the c7 clone now Queen g5
counter attacking the g2 pawn so white
has to be very careful not to just get
mated so like say g3 Queen it tries and
blacks idea is to somehow try and
maneuver the Queen to g2 or h1 because
either of these squares would be mating
squares so blacks plan it looks like in
this position is to play Queen 2 H 3 and
then Queen to d2 and this is kind of an
important concept when you're trying to
plan and chess sometimes what you end up
doing is identify the best place for a
piece and then figure out how to get
there so if you identify it
the Queen wants to go to g2 then you
figure out how does it Queen actually
get there and we can see very easily
Queen h3 Queen g2 this idea so why play
rook e3 and I don't know why locked in
play Queen h3 here would have been a
nice press let me ask you guys can you
find a way for white to defend against
Queen d2
yeah moving that one you can either play
a straight or f4 because when you move
the F on your queen I'm t2 depends
teacher
I like f3 and okay in this game black
didn't even friend checkmate black point
for f5 and whites I left for so white
has a really nice position like
everything kind of defends everything
the only undefended piece was the rook
on e3 but that can't really be attacked
and meanwhile this night is really
really good on me five because it's an
outpost that can't be attacked by a
black pawn so if we go forward the ship
to e4 is played attack and Queen Queen
e2 and eventually we're going to see the
blacks demise first of all losing the
pawn and then secondly in this position
white played a really good move which is
probably the most forcing move and if
I'm not mistaken I'm pretty sure this
move leads to force me
so black to move look for all the
possible checks or sorry white to move
look for all the possible checks very
good Queen c4 yeah and a problem for
black lives because a pawn move forward
there's an open line to attack the king
and after King h8 it's actually a really
kind of famous mating idea which occurs
in the game as the Queen and the knight
work together
I should mention like why it has a few
different ways to win here and I like to
easily just take the rook and be winning
but white side most precisely not a7
check 14 King g8 our white takes the
Queen King h8 and kind of the famous
idea which if you ask anyone who's rated
like above 1500 they'll know this idea
very very well is Queen g8 and it's kind
of the classic classic smothered mate
white is giving away the Queen to
smother the king surrounded by its own
pieces in that f7 so pretty nice ending
now not the most like perfect game but
another nice example of some attacking
ideas and I think maybe the biggest
thing to take away from this game was
earlier kind of the concept of figuring
out which pieces to trade them with
which pieces to keep on the board okay
how about we move on and I think we're
going to move to the game that everyone
has been waiting for and probably the
people on YouTube have already seen it's
the game from the video which was
released like one or two weeks ago
between Mike comer and I don't even know
the other guy's name I guess his last
name is banks jr. banks okay and if you
haven't seen the video uh you can link
it somewhere maybe up here or down here
and it's a very kind of cringe-worthy
game especially if you watch the video
because there's a lot of trash-talking
ton of blunders probably within the
first 5 moves of the game there were
enough blenders to last like this whole
session but well we'll try and not be
too means that the players will just try
and critique the move and try and learn
something
one thing or two so Mike Hummer playing
White's against junior banks efore I'm
sure my comer was hoping for some fried
liver with an eventual like Knight g5
and I take a seven that didn't happen
because black played the French defense
only after d4 it wasn't the French
defense it was whatever this was called
it's like the French and caro-kann which
like someone who's already like shaking
their head if you want to like leave now
you're welcome to and then you don't
have to like suffer through this but um
okay so c6 uh really no purpose behind
this move because what usually in the
French you want to play d5 and then you
want to follow up with c5 and when you
play c6 it's really just an oozing time
now my comer plays kind of an equally as
bad move here he tries to kind of
capitalize too quickly when he should
just like kind of play a more normal
movie play d5
completely overextending giving them
giving black the opportunity to play d6
which blacks as well plays d6 black or
white should have not overextended just
leave the pawns in the center and play
Bishop d3 and the first like six moves
were so difficult for me to look at
because like neither side develops any
pieces like they just kept pushing pawns
so e5 was played d6 was played and then
another bad move from light f4 again
just kind of overextending and if you
watch in the video like my comer was
playing with his I guess like he was
trying to make it physical and like
really intimidate his opponent by
playing this move like f4 but um chess
is not really a physical game where
you're supposed to like scare your
opponents and you like okay just play
Knight of three in develop so this was a
blitz game okay maybe I didn't mention
that yeah yeah okay sure enough so yeah
usually and blitz I guess the players
will or quality but but still step okay
f4 now there is a really interesting
opportunity for black to take advantage
of f4 I guess inputs maybe this is
harder spots but um you see it Queen h4
yeah and this is like so common whenever
a player moves their F pawn you got to
look for Queen h4 sometimes it doesn't
work but sometimes it's just winning in
this case maybe it's not winning but
it's good for black because what's going
to happen the Kings in check if the pawn
blocks and Queenie for wins the rook so
white is pretty much obliged to play
king d2 or Keeney to maybe King e2 is
best actually now that I look at this
position like both sides are kind of not
doing that creams like the Kings on
YouTube well Black has like no pieces
ready to come into the game other than
the Queen so I don't know what's going
on here actually I don't know what side
I would prefer but this was definitely
the best option for black instead what
happened black just kept pushing pawn
takes e5 and as I kind of said earlier
it's usually better for black to play c5
in one move rather than play C 6 and
then c5 and you kind of learn this type
of thing through making mistakes and
then learning from the experience now
we're on new 5 no pieces have been
developed now like Hummer finally
develops his bishop with check I'm sure
he said check in the video he had to
knight c6 and now now he played a very
questionable move maybe he played this
move because it's check and he could say
something but he kind of made the same
mistake that we saw in the previous game
where he trades off his bishop when it's
really not necessary hey Bishop takes c6
and especially when you're especially
when you're pinning a piece it's usually
not good to take that piece what you
want to do is apply more pressure and
maintain the pin so instead of Bishop
Jake's c6 okay like could play maybe
some of like 93 defend again against
Queen h4 maintain the pin this would
offer him some more chances
spot okay he gave away the bishop yeah
don't get along sure I will I would
almost recommend never trading off the
bishop for the night unless you're sure
that you're winning something that's the
general rule now there's always
exceptions and in different positions
sometimes it will make sense
positionally if you're fighting for a
square that's a knight's guarding
sometimes you want to trade it off but
most of the time especially in
situations like this when you're pinning
you don't want to take a pin piece you
want to apply pressure to live in peace
so one example actually kind of a cool
example might as well show it let's say
Knight f3 is played then let's say black
takes white could take back
and in doing so applies more pressure to
the night now we should note that the
Queen can't take night because that's a
free queen right we should also note
that like Queen h4 is possible but then
maybe just a move like King f1 and again
the Queen can't take the night because
uh because still depend on 9 MC 6 so
probably would have been the better
option for for whites now in the game
yeah
take take now you did mention double
pawns in this case the double pawns
aren't really that unfortunate for lack
for a few reasons
first of all the pawns are probably
going to be undone
after these pawns get traded secondly
the thing about double pawns is they can
open up more lines for the player who
has a double piles so in this position
the lines that opened up first of all is
a B file which could be useful also now
the bishop has opportunity to come to a
really nice agonal from Asics so I think
I think I would be relatively pleased as
black in this position game continues
903 finally we see some developments see
JP for Cleante P for Queen take e4
Knight takes e4 for after ten moves
there's only one developed piece on the
board black develops and now this was a
really interesting moment because okay
of course it was a list game and he look
in the video my comer is about to
automatically play Knight takes c6 like
without even thinking like free pawn why
not just take it and then he stops
himself because he realizes that
sometimes problems aren't always free
and in this position if Knight takes c6
he would have been severely punished
what can black do to basically win back
more than upon
so it should be seven hopefully everyone
agrees there should be seven is very
good curing the night in the rook
but there's more tactics that exist here
because when the light moves uh not too
many towards me like to move to let's
say not a five then black can take on G
to winning the pawn back and trapping
the work
so yeah the the c6 pawn is known as a
poison pot you take the poison you
basically die so if they go forward
Bishop c5 nine to three okay now the
game kind of starts to go and more
normal territory sides develops Knight
c3 Bishop b4 Bishop g2 now ok
interestingly enough black made the same
like this should take knight move
probably not necessary especially when
no one's attacking you
I could understand like if whites about
to play a treat and you could take but
if White's not even provoking you for
black it's probably better just to
continue development maybe play a move
like this with a six and get your pieces
into the game but okay this should take
c3 this should take c3 nice d5 but okay
this is uh this is actually looking
fairly balanced after kind of a rocky
start for both sides King D to castle
now Bishop a5 and this was actually a
really surprisingly good idea for my
comer because what my comer did was he
just left his Bishop on e5 and for a
very long time there is never a point
where the black rook could access d8 so
it's very difficult for black to fight
for the one of the only the only open
pile and this is a surprisingly good
positional move so I don't usually say
this but I was impressed by my comers
move so Bishop h6 now another impressive
move by Mike Connor this was maybe
slightly suspicious but b3
and this is actually simply preparing to
play c4 shutting out the bishop I'm a
six kicking away the night from it's
nice post time d5 and yeah we see my
comer like understand some positional
checks
rook a da c 494 King III chasing right
back and then we if we look at this
position and we look at blacks pieces
compared to white pieces and white light
just has the pieces on much better
squares and the white pieces do a very
good job at restricting the black pieces
and just to kind of give an example like
all the black pieces are restricted in
some way like the King and knights
health restrict this night because these
squares are off-limits this pawn on b3
restricts a black rook from ever
infiltrating a pawn on c4 just make
these green pawn on c4 restricts a
bishop and this Bishop on a5 restricts
either of the rooks from coming to d8 so
yeah well done my comer now the game
isn't over and okay it was a much longer
fight so we'll we'll go forward and I
might zoom through until the next kind
of critical moment h4 was played 97 h5
9f5 check King f29 h6 now rook a do you
want and this was this was White's kind
of eventual plan was to fully control
the D file because black can't fight for
it and then eventually get the rook to
the 7th now if you watch one of the
previous lectures on end games I did
like an hour-long lecture on pigs on the
seventh rank I don't personally like to
call them pigs but if you do get your
rook since i'm frank it's one of the
best kind of endgame concepts that you
can employ so after pawn g6 which is
kind of a bad move h sake g6 this Knight
is undefended and attacked when just one
upon so black realize that you play King
g7 white takes another pawn king take
and now rook d7 and this is just
complete domination for light every
single white piece well place black
meanwhile struggling tremendously
now black survives like amazingly enough
the game continued King g7 Wyland's a7
pawn rook at AIDS takes take and then
this position was reached I shouldn't
mention um rook d1 is a blunder should
possess in training mode what White has
to realize in this position is black as
a friend now of course in the game
white allowed the threat and black to
not execute the threat but let's imagine
that black is about to execute the
threat first of all what does black want
to do next with yeah so black wants to
play Bishop takes e4 taking advantage of
this kind of undefended Bishop on a5
next question is what should white due
to the cutting of the threat
yeah really just move the bishop
anywhere get your Bishop off kind of the
target square
I like this should be to you kind of
defensive but also aggressive because
you're attacking the knight and then
eventually you just want to play a four
just make sure the rook can't attack on
the a5 now after rook e1 a black had his
kind of big opportunity and this would
have allowed back to come back into the
game as after Bishop takes c4 white is
left white loses a pawn but that is left
with some weaknesses because they each
upon some lines can be taken with check
and I was also weak so if white takes
black takes a choose hanging 94 is
coming I think box winning another pawn
luckily for my cover a black played not
the best move Bishop CH and then V 4 and
I hope you guys know there's a term in
chess which kind of it's demonstrated
here where the bishop defended by the
pawn blocks the open file you guys know
what this is called if you have a minor
piece defended by upon blocking an open
file
it's called a four-post a four-post SOR
II post similar to an outpost using
outpost is like a knight defend of icon
which can't be attacked by another one
now I only learn this like a couple
years ago from another Grandmaster who
um has more expertise in transitional
chess and this is actually a common idea
especially when there's rooks trying to
infiltrate opening files if you can set
up a 4-post like this then you limit
like all the play from the room so game
continues Bishop a6 c5 let's zoom
forward the rooks do not get traded I
think if you're black here you're down
upon what you want to do is keep these
little pieces on the board and try and
make things complicated
that's usually the general strategy when
you're worse or you're at the
disadvantage you want to create chaos
so black kind of maintains the tension
king of fate thank you for so eventually
a trade is force take take
now Keeney seven and now the game
continues I'm probably going to zoom
through next several moves but the
important thing to point out it is
opposite colored bishops meaning quite
has a dark square Bishop black has a
light square Bishop and these positions
are not always easy to win even if
you're up on it sometimes it's hard to
break through this case White has only
one pass pawn I need to don't know if we
can call this past pawn rarely can move
forward so the rest of the game is kind
of like Commerce struggling to break
through in the position eventually he
does but took some the sticks from black
so zoom forward and let's get to the key
moment so blacks work actually activated
first attacking a pawn Bishop d6
I'm sure if you watch the video like my
comer is almost like jumping with joy
I'm especially after this move he's
staring black to take the pawn because
rook h8 is coming so black takes pawn
rook a case
seven and now do you think move from
white rook cafe and this moment kind of
made me really sad because if I were
black there's just one very clear
defensive move which has to be played
but black didn't play this move so look
that's very very good
I mean you have to come behind check the
King hold on to your ass pawn black legs
look beat you maybe not realizing that
rook athlete as possible maybe thinking
he's about to win before but when you
give away the f7 pawn this is pretty
fatal for black because now the G pawn
is a passed pawn and this is all white
needs to win the game so kini 847
candiates
g5 work out three King G fuller look
back to b3 and now actually pretty nice
technique by my comer gives away the D
pawn just plays g6 after take King g5
and after rook to b3 g7 check king h4
rook g6 um this is a nice smooth
bye-bye white how does white win this
position very good rotate seven you just
want to kind of come from the other side
and then eventually delivered the check
on the back neck so work a7 and it's
pretty difficult to stop the idea of
brocade
so yeah I know it's kind of fun to
criticize my comer but he actually did
some good things this game a lot of not
so good things from both sides but
enough good things to win the game so
good job Mike
wherever you are in this world we can
move on and we have like five minutes
left so we have you game we can go over
but I wanted to open up up to you guys
if you guys have any questions you guys
are the viewers you can choose any
specific questions or we could just do
another game
another game ok let's let's try and find
like an entertaining game a board let's
see we can look at the toxic Hunter game
actually let's look at this game I think
this this was a relatively interesting
game we'll just try and doom drill look
at the critical points this was sent in
by someone named saman and he said he
really likes our show your choice which
i get he recommends that we changed the
name to your choice rather than 0th
choice and he said that this game was
determined by just one plot and I looked
at the game because I didn't trust him
when I read that the game was just
determined by one pond and I saw the
game and it was kind of actually just
determined by one pot I was actually
kind of impressive so let's zoom forward
we'll get to kind of a key position
nimzo-indian some weird moves were
played early on maybe black south is a
little bit questionable white did
something which looks good here but is
actually a mistake efore can be punished
black to move what's the best move g5
and yeah it's unfortunate when you're
like taking over the center but just
took over the assignment too early and
problems for white is uniform out
hanging because of this pin but that was
missed
there's B 7 is played let's zoom forward
even more and what actually happened
because some man who is playing white
and he was down upon for good portion of
the game and they got somewhere in this
position another example of the pig on
the 7th I was actually like kind of
annoying for black to deal with because
white has is it's really active rock in
blacksburg for passive the bishop was
also passive and black made this move c6
here which I didn't really like because
what it allows like to do is play g6 and
then just cement the rook on e7 then
it's very hard to to kind of deal with
whites really active
actively faced pieces but the game
continues rook se 822 and now this is
interesting because now upon get to e7
like still down upon and but upon the
seventh really has to be taken seriously
and especially when you ever have a pawn
either like on the six or the seventh
and your whites you always want to pay
attention to like that pawn promotion
tactics and there are a few missed
opportunities in this game but later on
likely to play pretty well so Queenie
six was played the other thing about
this position is that if white loses v7
pawn for free it's probably just going
to be a straightforward one for black
but if I can keep the e7 pond then
that's what's going to give white to
best chance
so rook e1 a logical move rook e8 and
now simples discover the top from White
Queen d2 this is an attack on the
Queen's eg-6 Queen g4 now this is a
really interesting position and you'd
have to kind of make an observation here
this between is defending the descent
pot so white skull in this position is
to remove the Queen from g4 so he can
play Queen take thee seven and the
question becomes is there a way to make
the Queen move away from g4 any ideas s3
is what black played and this almost
works but fails because f3 is to
weakening and we'll see that after f3
Queen f5y played g4 looks like we're
driving away the Queen from g7 but then
there's a civilian queen c5 check and
white doesn't have time to take on b7
unfortunately the better move very
similar to s3 is just a ch3 because now
as Queen on 5 g4 actually works there's
no Queen moving with check and wherever
the Queen moves they clean up 6 then we
just take on b7 that's waiting for white
so not the easiest tactic to find but
you kind of have to make observations
which leads you to finding this uh kind
of simple kind of not so simple move h3
what happened the game after he was
playing queen a5g4 queen escapes with
check queen III defending check and
defending the pawn queens get traded
when I first saw this position I thought
blacks should just easily win the pawn
and win the game but that's not what
happened he v was played 92 so black has
a very straightforward plan of flanking
f7 taking the pawn white played night g3
making sure that if King a7 it could be
met with Knight to f5 and then depending
upon and also there's all these four
possibilities black is actually
guaranteed to get pork for no matter
what what happens
so black by g6 here which looks good
preventing Knight f5 again threatening
king f7 but then white was really
resourceful white played h4 and after
king f7 h5 and the point became that
black really didn't have any time to
take on u7 because of birthday geese
Evan
there's plunge a g6 black hunter than a
quagmire so what happened was after h5
black took and then like out there like
a 5 and then White's pieces were just
overpowering 96 is coming good luck
stopping it so black played King g6 96
is played and whites just completely
winning now before just take a check
rook back and black was forced to give
away the rook and white one I don't how
this how long this game ended up going
to long black didn't resign
praying for stalemate okay finally
reputation so I thought this was a
really cool game because it showed that
yeah white had like a very far
overextended pawn but that pawn turned
out to be more of a strength than a
weakness
and I guess his rating was only 1,400
but it was pretty impressive play so I
think we'll end it with that and don't
forget submit your games and maybe we'll
have more more interesting games to look
at next time thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]